pour ne pas oublier la chine
une réplique de la statue de la liberté
qui avaient été élevés place tienanmen
une réplique donc a été érigé tout à
l'heure au parc de la villette à paris à
pékin
dans le même temps les autorités parlent
eux de mansuétude pour les
contestataires
jérôme ni sorti de l'ombre de l'un des
leaders du mouvement étudiant chinois
wu'er kaixi réfugié en france dans la
clandestinité depuis plusieurs jours il
est apparu au public pour la première
fois depuis la répression du printemps
de pékin pour l'inauguration de cette
réplique parisienne de la fameuse déesse
de la démocratie érigé par les étudiants
place tiananmen a battu par les chats
dans la nuit du 3 au 4 juin
ambiance plus détendue à paris pas qu'à
pékin